hi guys I'm Victoria lit
and I suffer from TWD
TWD is well the medical terms for it is traditional wife disease
it's been dormant from a young age
and the prognosis for this probably originated from my traditional Latina mother
so basically what TWD is
when you're married or with
you're with a man
you cook, clean,
do his laundry,
do everything for him.
basically you just wanna do anything to please him.
a lot of women actually suffer from this disease,
and it goes undiagnosed because they haven't found a good man yet.
so they don't even realize they have it
now this disease scares most women
um they're terrified of contracting it
it's understandable
because they think that it's enslavement
when actually it's enrichment in your life
it's actually a gift
so I just wanted to kind of be a spokesperson for someone who suffers with TWD
and just you know
tell you that you're not alone in this
we're in this together
first example of how I knew I had trad wife disease
was that when I first met him
I had these butterflies in my stomach
and I automatically just wanted to do anything to please him.
it was a huge tell, of how I knew I had this disease
I started cooking for him,
cleaning for him,
doing all his laundry,
doing anything to make him happy!
which was kind of crazy,
because I didn't think I'd ever do this for a man.
but that was a huge tell
another example is,
if he mentioned something in passing that he liked once
I would automatically store that in my memory
I would either make whatever he said he liked or prepare anything
I would just do whatever he liked
that was huge
that was kind of crazy
the last sign of how I knew I had TRAD wife disease
was that. Any time I was with my man
I would just,
my brain would turn off.
like I would just
my brain turned off
that was scary at first,
I didn't know what to do!
but you know,
after learning the signs and symptoms of tradwife disease
I learned that, that's actually a good thing
because he provides so much for me,
that he leads for me
So I don't have to use my brain
I can just turn it off
and that's actually a gift in itself
so don't be scared
if you suffer from tradwife disease
I'm here with you
we can get through this